vous êtes fait pas fort boyard vous
alors je vous dire la vérité et dieu
sait si hélas je ne mens pas ouais
olivier minne et un ami c'est vrai on a
des jeunes âgés de moins que moi moi que
benjamin est ce que moi et moi déjà bel
et bien finie pourquoi olivier qui était
un ami
moi j'ai sonné en voilà seul ami guy moi
je suis très pote avec willy j'aime
beaucoup je vais très pote avec oui je
suis très pote avec des fines et c'est
vrai voilà est par contre vous je vous
suis pas ce n'est pas de la mythique
qu'est ce que tu voulais dire par-là non
écrite par là c'est que je me suis
toujours dit c'est étonnant que on
s'entend si bien avec olivier j'ai
jamais été invité et je crois qu'un jour
le fond de l'histoire
on a dit on a dit à l'époque que comme
j'ai fait nrj12 et que moi même j'ai une
très mauvaise image certainement une
image vulgaire adulé vision aussi bien
ici que sur nrj 12 ans on a dit de leurs
mots sur fort boyard ou sur france
télévisions mais et d'ailleurs ça se
confirme puisque je n'ai jamais été
habité aucune rémission même que nagui
avait fait léger pas quoi les la
spéciale sur n'oubliera les pains mais
voilà il y avait six passes en personne
était un gagneur gala 100 personnes à la
fin même de production de la vie on a du
mal à les ascendants qu'à la fin les 5-6
dernières c'est personne ne connaissait
mais de leurs mots jamais et c'est vrai
que je n'ai jamais mis les pieds sur
france télévisions de ma vie et ça se
confirme a juré que je n'ai jamais
entendu ça sur toi voilà dans le câble a
poussé jusque là je n'ai jamais reçu une
invitation chez lui à les gens ne
pensent pas vous l'invitez peut-être
free island celebrity jamais de la vie
avec l aquila signer pour l'année
prochaine et me dit pas de leurs mots
que ton propre et mon nom mais juré
promis
jamais je n'ai entendu me sens encore
plus humiliant donc on n'a jamais
proposé mon aval
on verra on va essayer de vous faire
faire fort boyard l'année prochaine
d'accord c'est gentil non mais sans
rigoler oui